welcome to this video playing felon from
Germany actually so yeah I lost a bad
game with the open Sicilian just very
brief brief time we go there's something
else I think it can also play this move
just going from standard type of
development no maybe not not too bad
looks like why does got a healthy
position now maybe drop back and then
Heidi for next and maybe I could have
gone to be three actually okay it's an
experimental opening anyway ok ok I want
to I want to play d4 when I want to
prepare not run into Bishop g4
yeah this is almost always a pretty
serious concession to take because I'm
getting Knight c3 but maybe he's trying
to simplify a bit I mean maybe he's
trying to he is simplifying a bit it
still looks so quite nice for white I
just am ft 6 as a welcome a weakness to
attack you cannot really play d5 it
looks like there's too much happening on
the efl d5 takes takes takes at the end
e7 is always the problem not sure I'm
just threatening look T 1 not sure how
it is supposed to prevent it ok yeah I
prevent it in them let's say mechanical
Hessian just rook cat6 mmmm yeah
probably not a bad move how to proceed
now
who
maybe Bishop tutu f3 not sure this gives
away c4 which might be a problem yeah I
don't like the plan ready right after I
played it now interesting there I didn't
expect okay let's let's play the endgame
I'm really not sure if this was supposed
a good decision maybe it's no big deal
but first impression is that it it
should help me I bet okay not clear
what's position is also bit fragile here
with them on the queenside the bishop e6
is always attacking a to cannot really
play three and that's not not quite
clear orders i'm also not threatening
now to take because there's always
betraying as well so i really cannot
take
hmm
I have an idea maybe this is can be a
can be an idea night night d for
provoking provoking the night to move
and then I play Bishop g4 intending to
get rid of the light squared Bishop my
light square Bishop is an exactly great
and even after taking on e6 it's still a
week fall on d6 not sure but maybe this
is this is an idea right he doesn't have
fun some spectacular answer to that I
wonder 95 maybe night to d5 using this
this sort of pinning situation after
taking on d5 I can take d 7 why not ass
let's go to the center 93 as a possible
idea as well don't let F form there
there are some ideas it's a bit it's
slightly uncomfortable for him I believe
at least at least I would feel a bit
uncomfortable sorry pretty sure about
that
maybe this one
hmm cannot take what about f3 is this a
ridiculous move it looks a bit
ridiculous of three
yeah but I don't see what he what he can
do about it looks a bit strange the
bishop and the despot but it seems he
has no great reply and I can reroute my
preserved my pieces later 93-5 for
instance 93 f 5
to know what is this one this is good
what I need to do is supply e5 here
maybe I should just threaten that yeah
this is also nice hmm still if five yeah
probably be five need to use this if it
takes know if it takes Bishop c5 rock
rock be five maybe how to play that you
should see 8 we should see 8 it takes
takes rook 28 notes much not sure about
that or is 6 now come on let's go asics
cannot spend much more time
check
time warning
yeah unfortunately I really have lost
the thread that looked it looked really
bad for black but I didn't manage to
make anything out of it
check
black resins more didn't expected yeah
quite lucky I mean I completely lost the
thread here it looked excellent i mean
this looks hear about right here than
white should be in good shape computer
thinks it's a drone metal probably
around here the certain you want
something and you probably need to be a
bit more precise but ok let's just I'm
curious about about this mmm our
computer wants to take first and then e
five yeah maybe this is more precise
possible yeah now is six now I played
this but what now check
oh look at five is no winning why
because I can take f8 hahaha this is
nice I have a look at this thing I
didn't see that at all yeah getting the
rook I can't let this okay here i'm
struggling but it is still there's still
some fight in it i still have the two
bishops and he's got quite bad pieces I
don't know it was a matter of the time
also we both were down on the clock
thanks for watching